PUT TEN OR 20 OR 30,000 PEOPLE
IN ONE PLACE.
MY POINT IS, I THINK YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
>> Laura: LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, MEET JOE BIDEN, THE
SCIENCE GUY.
THAT DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION WHICH
IS STILL MONTHS AWAY MAY NEED TO
BE CANCELED.
JOINING ME NOW IS TEXAS
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
SENATOR, YOU FELT THIS COMING,
DID YOU NOT?
IT’S GOING TO BE KEEP THIS GOING
THROUGH THE FALL SO WE DON’T
HAVE TOUGH CONVENTIONS, PROBABLY
NOT EVEN A CAMPAIGN.
AND MAYBE NOT EVEN TRADITIONAL
VOTING.
IT ALL HAS TO BE DONE BY MAIL.
>> I THINK BIDEN IS TERRIFIED OF
THE BERNIE BROTHERS, HE DOESN’T
WANT TO GO TO A CONVENTION
BECAUSE HE SCARED OF THE
ACTIVISTS.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A PRESUMPTIVE
NOMINEE HIDE FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN?
IT’S UNPRECEDENTED.
>> Laura: I WOULD NEVER SAY
ANYTHING LIKE IT AND I WOULD
NEVER SAY ANYTHING LIKE PEOPLE
CONCLUDING MANY MONTHS OUT THAT
THINGS NEED TO BE CANCELED, OR
THINGS NEED TO BE VIRTUAL WHICH
MEANS THEY ARE CERTAINLY NOT AS
MEANINGFUL FOLKS.
SO WHY DO THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
NEED TO DO THAT NOW?
BUT YOU GET THE SENSE THAT THE
DEMOCRATS FEEL, THEY FEEL LIKE
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE A CHANCE AGAINST
TRUMP TO KEEP THIS THING GOING
ALL THE WAY TO THE FALL?
>> I THINK THEY ARE SCARED OF
WHATEVER GAPS, AND ALSO YOU SEE
MUCH OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
TRYING TO ROOT FOR DISASTER.
THEY ARE TRYING TO ROOT FOR THIS
PANDEMIC TO BE WORSE AND WORSE.
YOU SAW "THE WASHINGTON POST"
SELF-PROCLAIMED FACT-CHECKER WAS
CHEERING ABOUT A LINE FROM THE
STATE OF THE UNION WHERE THE
PRESIDENT SAID WE HAD THE LATEST
ON EMPLOYMENT IN 50 YEARS AND,
WE HAD THE LOWEST
AFRICAN-AMERICAN AND HISPANIC
UNEMPLOYMENT EVER REPORTED.
UNTIL A GLOBAL PANDEMIC THAT
ORIGINATED IN WUHAN, IN CHINA,
AND ENDED UP CAUSING ABSOLUTE
CHAOS AND CATASTROPHE.
THE MEDIA SHOULD BE COMING
TOGETHER TO ROOT FOR AMERICA, TO
ROOT FOR DEFEATING THE PANDEMIC,
AND I THINK TOO MANY PARTISAN
DEMOCRATS WANT TO JUST USE THIS
CATASTROPHE TO ATTACK TRUMP
RATHER THAN COME TOGETHER AND
FIGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: HERE’S WHAT BIDEN
SAID YESTERDAY ABOUT BANNING
TRAVEL OVER THE VIRUS.
>> 45 NATIONS HAD ALREADY MOVED
TO BLOCK CHINA’S PERSONNEL FROM
BEING ABLE TO COME OUT OF THE
STATES BEFORE THE PRESIDENT
MOVED.
IT’S ABOUT PACE, IT’S ABOUT THE
URGENCY AND I DON’T THINK THERE
HAS BEEN ENOUGH OF IT.
>> Laura: THAT’S A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT TUNE THAT HE WAS
SINGING BACK IN JANUARY.
>> THIS IS NO TIME FOR
DONALD TRUMP’S RECORD OF
HYSTERICAL JENNA PHOBIA AND
FEARMONGERING TO LEAD THE WAY
INSTEAD OF SCIENCE.
>> Laura: WHY WAS THAT GOOD
SCIENCE IN JANUARY BUT NOT GOOD
SCIENCE TODAY?
>> IT’S POLITICAL OPPORTUNISM.
THE PRESIDENT AT THE TIME SAID
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO?
HE WAS GETTING BLASTED AND
CALLED A HYSTERICAL XENOPHOBE.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAS RUNNING
EDITORIALS FROM OP-ED COLUMNIST
BLASTING HIM FROM PUTTING THAT
CHINA BAN IN PLACE.
THIS CORONAVIRUS IS TOO
DANGEROUS AND ALL OF US NEED TO
DO WHAT WE CAN TO PROTECT
PEOPLE’S LIVES AND SAFETY.
THE CDC, I CHAIRED A HEARING ON
THE CORONAVIRUS OVER A MONTH AGO
AND THE CITY CDC SAID, SUBSTANTI
SLOWING THE GROWTH OF THE VIRUS
IN THE UNITED STATES AND REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF INFECTIONS AND IT
SAVES LIVES IN AMERICA.
AND YET RIGHT NOW JOE BIDEN AND
PELOSI ON THE PRESS ARE ALL
TRYING TO WRITE HISTORY TO
PRETEND THEY SUPPORTED WHAT THEY
CRITICIZE IN THE POST AT THE
TIME.
>> Laura: SENATOR CHRIS PELOSI
SAYING THE NEXT BILL WILL BE A
TRILLION DOLLARS.
NOW YOU ARE A FISCAL HAWK AND I
THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF FISCAL
HAWKS THAT SAY THEY ARE BUT NOT
REALLY, BUT A LOT OF STUFF SHE
IS FLOATING, THE GREEN NEW DEAL
AND THE GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE, WE
HAVE TO GET BACK TO WORK.
IF WE DON’T GET BACK TO WORK WHO
WILL PAY THE TAB HERE?
>> THERE’S NO DOUBT WE HAVE TO
GET BACK TO WORK.